we now have another poll that just came
out a signal poll from November showing
that that Donald Trump is leading Joe
Biden among independent voters right now
among Independents it's not even all
that close Trump 44 Biden 38 18
undecided so you know could swing either
way but Trump is leading among all
voters Biden is still beating Trump 47
to
45 but you might say okay well that's
evidence that we need to replace Trump
with some other Republican but according
to the poll Joe Biden is doing even
better against a generic Republican so
Biden beats Trump by two points it head
to-head Biden beats a generic Republican
by four points but usually the generic
Republican would be doing better because
the generic Republican is just a blank
slate that you could project whatever
you want onto in this case however it's
flipped which means that once you
replace generic Republican with any of
the other candidates the numbers are
going to get even
worse whether you hate the guy or love
the guy Donald Trump is just something a
little a little bit different in
politics you saw this when he rolls up
to UFC with Tucker Carlson Don Jr Kid
Rock and Dana White and The Crowd Goes
Crazy how strong that team is making his
way into the building one of the bigger
mixed martial arts fans I know president
Donald Trump taking his octagon side
seat for UFC
[Applause]
we got two title fights coming up at UFC
295 here in a matter of moments live
from Madison Square
Garden and president Trump will be here
to witness all of it four of the very
there he is they're going
crazy imagine Mitt Romney walking into
the UFC
Stadium what wait oh who is that M okay
never mind let's go get a beer you know
it's it's not it's not Trump and Tucker
It's Mitt Romney and Jake Tapper walking
into the stadium and The Crowd Goes Wild
no of course not
and this is by the way this is Trump
what what are we at now eight years
after he first declared he was running
for
president and then one the following
year and even after all that the crowd
still loves him but it's not the crowd
of the nice Washington DC Think Tank set
many of whom hate his guts it's not the
crowd that reacts to the Mitt Romney of
the world it's the UFC fans with one
exception the comedian Bill Burr was
sitting there and he's sitting there and
he's looking respectful as Trump walks
by they're all sitting you know ringside
and Bill Burr's wife flips off Donald
Trump right in front of the camera and
everybody is attacking Bill Burr and
Bill Burr's wife for this I think I'm
GNA lay off him one I think Bill Burr is
a pretty funny guy what his what his
wife did is extremely unfortunate and
sad and if it were my it would never be
my wife because sweet little Alisa is a
civilized woman but you know if it were
my wife we'd probably have a little chat
when we got home and say no you know
honey it's actually very bad to
disrespect the former president of the
United States uh on national television
and you just that's and just to behave
like that generally as a lady as really
anyone in public is very vulgar and not
good right now go to expressvpn.com
Michels show it's extremely important to
protect your online privacy with a VPN
and choosing a VPN you trust is equally
as important I can say with full
confidence that expressvpn is the best
VPN on the market here's why number one
expressvpn does not log your online
activity they've developed a trusted
server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all number two speed
expressvpn does not slow down your user
experience you can even stream HD videos
with zero buffering number three
expressvpn is incredibly easy to use
just fire up that app and tap one button
to connect not just me saying this
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate Express VPN the
number one VPN in the world protect
yourself with a VPN that I trust use my
link expressvpn.com noow today get 3
months free on a one-year package
expressvpn.com
noow expressvpn.com
Michels show today but I'm not going to
attack Bill bur I'm not really going
after his wife too hard for this
because I'm sure most people out there
myself excluded most people out there
have been with their spouses in public
and the spouse has done something kind
of embarrassing and it's I'm sure Bill
Burr is mortified by this and so I don't
Bill he's a funny guy he's I'm not going
to I'm not going to attack him for it
it's very unfortunate but in a way it's
kind of a nice Silver Lining here
because more than a silver lining it's
it's actually affirmatively helpful for
the Republicans and for Trump because it
shows you the contrast one bill bur's
wife attacking Trump gets people talking
about this and then what are people
looking at how big was that Stadium I'm
going to pull a number at a thin air
let's say it was 20,000 people that
means
19,999 people in that Stadium were
thrilled to see Trump the presumptive
Republican nominee Tucker the biggest
Cable News host and right-wing Cable
News host ever in all of history Kid
Rock very prominent right-wing musician
who blew up Bud Light with a machine
gun they all loved him one person one
very loud person did not like him I
don't know to me I like those numbers
not saying it means Trump's going to win
I'm not saying I would bet any money
that Trump is going to win in a general
election we know that the Democrats are
very good at rigging things and the
people can be fickle too but in a fair
election when I'm looking at not just
one poll which could be faked not just
two polls which could be faked but I'm
looking at all the evidence available to
me in a fair election I like the
Republican chances the other question
about UFC here is what's Tucker doing
there what's what's Tucker Carlson doing
there at that
fight is Trump floating Tucker for
VP some have suggested it I've floated
this idea for years at this point seems
crazy right if I were Tucker two years
ago I probably wouldn't want this why
why would why would he want it he's
making tens of millions of dollars a
year at Fox News he's got a very
prominent perch he's the most
influential conservative on television
why would he well but then Fox News took
that from him so he's still extreme
influential he's still doing great but
he's got less to lose in terms of money
less to lose in terms of
influence and the B loves him who else
could run with Trump that the bass
loves none of the people currently
running for president none of the ones
who were on that debate stage the the
nearest who could run with Trump would
probably be vake but he's he's probably
just too fresh and young to to be really
I don't know I mean maybe he could he's
talented guy but it's not going to be
Christie it's not going to be Nikki
Haley it's not going to be Tim Scott
it's not going to be Ronda santis at
this point couldn't be Ronda santis
because they're both from
Florida so it constitutionally wouldn't
even work if they wanted to win the
election so who's it going to be could
be some of these guys that no one really
knows about Byron Donalds as a
republican Congressman his name has been
floated could be Carri Lake you know but
she lost her race for governor I just
don't Tucker though he's really popular
and he represents a the Trump win of the
party he represents the Buchanan wing of
the party he represents the conservative
wing of the conservative movement in a
way that the other candidates simply
don't I don't know look maybe Trump was
just out there going to take in a nice
fight with his buddy Tucker or maybe
this was a little weather balloon maybe
they were just floating something I
don't know what do you think of the
thing that they might have been
floating what do you think about that
man what a great clip that was now hey
hey hey hey hey hey hey you got to ring
that Bell subscribe to the Michael NS
YouTube channel see you next time